gun control will be on the agenda today
in the first state that will help decide
the 2020 election with the Iowa State
Fair in full swing a few miles away the
leading Democratic presidential
candidates will share their solutions to
gun violence at a forum in downtown Des
Moines ed O'Keefe is in Iowa at good
morning good morning Dana this is one of
the political big biggest political
weekends of the year here in Iowa
hundreds of thousands of people go to
that State Fair that you mentioned but
for the Democratic presidential
candidates it began last night they
shared the stage at a chicken wing
dinner will fundamentally change who we
are as a nation
together we will protect American
democracy and the rule of law and
together we will create an economy and a
government that works for all 20
Democrats who want to be President and
just five minutes each to make their
case Democratic presidential candidates
are here again in Iowa this weekend for
a series of events stops at the State
Fair and visits across the Hawkeye State
here in Iowa polling puts former Vice
President Joe Biden on top Massachusetts
senator Elizabeth Warren is in second
one else trailing on Saturday most of
the candidates are set to speak at a
forum on gun violence organized just in
the last few days since the mass
shootings in Ohio and Texas ahead of the
forum former housing secretary who Leon
Castro released a new plan to tackle gun
violence and extremism my plan would
combat white nationalism domestic
terrorism by enacting gun safety
legislation that would make it harder
for guns to get into the hands of
people can you really though legislate
and spend away that kind of ideology and
thought and hate well I think that we
can catch it sooner before it actually
turns into violence
voters at the fair have different views
on what to do about mass shootings
owning a weapon which I believe is our
right is also a big responsibility and
so I would like to see some some better
background checks that gun forum is
sponsored by various gun control
organizations including some bankrolled
by the former New York City Mayor
Michael Bloomberg it's telling the
Democrats feel so confident discussing
the issue of gun control that they're
gonna do it here in a state like Iowa
meanwhile nine more candidates will be
over at the State Fair today to give you
a sense of the sheer size of this
presidential field all of these
candidates are holding at least 30
different events across the state of
Iowa today Jeff good luck covering all
of it who are you will thank you very
much